time now for pft on yahoo sports peter
king mike florio some of the big stories
in the national football league and in
honor of election day peter we're going
to cast our ballot for the first half
sort of mvp of the 2020 season if we
were casting that ballot today which
player would you pick
i'd pick russell wilson uh mike i think
on his way to
leading the seahawks uh basically to
even though i like
tampa bay a lot
you know i've been sort of sobered up by
some of their close calls
and uh i think seattle really is going
to end up being the best team in the nfc
uh because they will get defensive
pieces back but they will be the best
team in the nfc because they know that
every week they've got a guy who can put
30 plus points on the board
with a much lesser supporting cast than
patrick mahomes has
and and really mike you know after
as we enter the first uh you know the
halfway point of the season
russell wilson you know has a higher
quarterback rating than mahomes they're
each plus 20 touchdown to interception
ratio thrown for more
passing yards per game
and you know a better rating so to me i
i just think even though mahomes has
been terrific aaron rodgers been very
good
you know until very recently
i think russell wilson for the first
half of the season in total has been the
most valuable player
26 touchdown passes six interceptions in
only seven games mahomes has 21
touchdown passes one interception in
eight games and yes russell wilson with
the higher passer rating and i agree
with you
the lack of the supporting cast and also
peter this is something we've discussed
in the past you've written about it this
season that top seed dynamic right now
the seahawks top seed in the nfc and i
think the mvp ultimately comes from
one of the top two seeds in the
conferences and if the season were over
today it would be seattle coming out of
the nfc with that one loss and russell
wilson would be the mvp
yeah i'm probably not going to adhere to
that but certainly it helps
if you uh pilot your team
to one of the best records in football
that should mean something
what means more to me is that
i believe that
and again i don't want to penalize
patrick mahomes for a great supporting
cast
you shouldn't do that
but i do want to credit russell wilson
for being on pace for a 59
touchdown pass season
and he's got one mega weapon at wide
receiver and that's dk metcalf he's got
a very pedestrian backfield
and a pedestrian situation at tight end
too
so i just think this is the year
it's setting up right now for russell
wilson to finally win it
and i say this in jest but if that mega
weapon dk metcalf at receiver continues
to play like he has or like he did on
sunday when they actually throw him the
ball he may siphon votes away from
russell wilson
yeah the unfortunate thing about the mvp
and we've discussed it mike is that
you know because
there are 50 voters and they have one
vote each
it's very unlikely that dk metcalf will
siphon a single vote away from russell
wilson even if he has an incredible
season
because
if you look at it and you can only vote
for one guy
then
you know how do you vote for dk metcalf
over russell wilson
you know it's been a very rare
occurrence
in nfl history where you look at a
situation and say yeah the mvp is a wide
receiver you know it's it's almost
always you know since adrian peterson
now it's almost always been the
quarterback and i think russell wilson
finally is going to get his
2017 there was some talk of antonio
brown late in the season being an mvp
candidate but that obviously didn't
materialize and russell wilson who's had
zero mvp votes because of the dynamic
that peter explained
he may get all of them this year we'll
see we're halfway there and uh nine more
weeks before we get to the point
hopefully we get nine weeks in before we
get to the point where they cast the
ballots on the mvp that's it for this
edition of pft on yahoo sports he's
peter king i'm mike florio we'll see you
next time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports